[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti
viviamo in un momento pazzesco abbiamo
tutto tutto alziamo le tapparelle col
telefonino
guardiamo le partite in streaming
ordiniamo sui cimentano in bagno abbiamo
tutto tutto e tutto ciò che abbiamo è
nuovo
ora non è più come prima no per esempio
se io devo uscire con una ragazza cioè
che ci esco e spero che vada bene no
prima faccio una radiografia dei suoi
social network mi vado a imparare a
memoria anche il cane della morosa della
ragazza della migliore amica della sua
zia esco il mio libro preferito è guida
integrati che abbia avuto stoppies t no
pure il mio è il mio sogno il mio sogno
è quello di liberare gli ermellini dagli
allevamenti intensivi no che il mio
sposiamoci siamo uguali com'è possibile
è possibile perché abbiamo accesso a
tutto
no i vostri figli no sempre col
telefonino leggono guardano non chiedono
più niente i genitori niente non gli
stavano più i genitori a cosa servono i
genitori adesso sono i figli che servono
i genitori come si accede alla smart tv
scusa e come si scarica questa amore
come cosa è successo barcellona ma cos'è
la break sit ma come posso fare sesso
con tua madre
amore in questo momento non ci rendiamo
conto delle potenzialità che abbiamo è
tutto così normale no perché è
normalissimo è normalissimo vedere la
parata militare di kimi giorni mentre
sto mangiando la pizza cioè normalissimo
che ordino dei pantaloni dall america e
mi tornano in due giorni cioè è
normalissimo che io sblocco il telefono
con l'impronta digitale è normalissimo
no è che tutti insieme
viviamo in un momento pazzesco non lava
detto nessuno insieme
viviamo in un momento pazzesco
soprattutto per noi giovani no alcune
volte quello dei giovani scatto
stati cioè scazzati in questo è che
palle devo mettermi le scarpe per andare
a scuola in questo momento
come fai a essere scacciato fare musica
vuoi fare musica prendo il computer
scarichi ableton fai una canzone la
metti su soundcloud la lotta un
produttore fai un album fai un concerto
20 mila persone e il tuo unico dubbio è
se la terza casa da compiere mare o in
montagna
puoi fare un app vuoi fare una app vuoi
fare una prendi un computer ci fa venire
in mente un'idea inizia a programmare
sceglie un logo la mette online download
telegiornali investitori start up
silicon valley e dice a zuckerberg se
ogni tanto permettersi una giacca invece
che la tuta to2 fare giornalismo il
giornalismo giornalismo comincia a
leggere scrivere un'inchiesta la mette
online ri condividono i giornali ti
chiamano in tv immigrazione clandestina
e ti lamenti perché la cpa ti mettono la
cipria prima di entrare in scena
e poi se vuoi fare foto welfare foto 20
euro per andare a londra 10 euro per
andare ad amsterdam 8 euro per avere
berlino 6 euro per andare a barcellona
gratis il dx di treviso ragazzi se i
giovani sono scattati in questo momento
è perché non hanno capito che possono
diventare chiunque in una settimana in
una settimana
viviamo in un momento pazzesco pazzesco
non ci sono delle regole non c'è un
percorso predefinito sono mille modi per
arrivare a cosa si vuole fare
anche perché i lavori che vanno adesso
sono quelli che fino a dieci anni fa non
esistevano nemmeno tu a karl marx che
fai il digital strategist il seo
specialist il content web editor il
digital pr
il web analyst di virtù a karl marx che
fa il fashion blogger
diglielo tu e allora non solo ci sono
lavori che prima non esistevano ci sono
anche lavori che non esistono proprio
vi chiedo a voi vi chiedo a voi adesso
ditemi che lavoro è gestire una pagina
facebook che commenta ironicamente le
espressioni di personaggi di quadri
principalmente post medievali ditemelo
esiste no non esiste perché ormai ormai
non ce ne saranno più i nomi dei lavori
ci saranno i nomi di chi li fa siamo
nell'era della personalizzazione del
lavoro non si sa cosa accadrà
non si sa ma la possibilità di
trasformare la propria passione in un
lavoro è concreta e noi giovani dovremmo
impazzire all'idea che la passione
personale non ha mai avuto così tanti
sbocchi lavorativi come oggi viviamo in
un momento pazzesco pazzesco perché
perché in tutto questo grande
cambiamento di tutto questo grande
novità in tutto questo nuovo sistema la
scuola ci insegna la tettonica a placche
la scuola ci insegna la tettonica a per
carità cioè la città unica placche
non ho nulla contro quante e quante ne
abbiamo evitate grazie alla tettonica a
placche quante ma la scuola dovrebbe
darci stimoli dovrebbe darci gli
strumenti per poter esprimere noi stessi
dovrebbe farsi capire che cambiare il
mondo è possibile e non solo dovrebbe
orientarci orientarci la scuola dovrebbe
passare la maggior parte del suo tempo a
orientarci farsi capire cosa ci piace
perché perché per tu esci dalla maturità
ma lo maturano la barba la partita iva
diciottenne ma tutto bello maturo la
maturità e se siete ubriaco festeggio la
festeggio
ma che festeggi ma che festa di festa ma
che festeggi che non sai cosa vuoi fare
non l'hai mai capito non hai mai avuto
il tempo di capire cosa ti piace
e vabbè farò farò di giurisprudenza nome
3000 tolgano economia e mercoledì
economia il mercoledì o tennis filosofi
norma filosofia no il mcdonald's no non
fa per me il mcdonald e prete vuoi fare
il prete non lo so
e allora cosa facciamo in preso un anno
sabbatico per pensare cosa mi piace
quando dovresti uscire dalla scuola che
lei spaccare tutto
tutto deve uscire deve essere gasato
levi voler spaccare tutto quando esci
dalla scuola invece va all'università
passano due anni fa è tranquillo sa
forse capisce che non è quello che ti
piaceva e vai avanti e vai avanti fa il
master fa il tirocinio fai lo stage vai
avanti i tuoi non ti hanno più soldi tu
devi lavorare vai avanti fai un figlio
due figli la figlia
finalmente la figlia fino a ogni tanto
l'italia visse i mondiali e muori muori
viviamo in un momento pazzesco pazzesco
in cui le nostre idee potrebbero
viaggiare in tutto il mondo
l'idea che ho io per il mio paese può
essere buona per tutto il mondo adesso
io ve lo dico vi dico tutto questo
perché se non fosse per questo momento
pazzesco
io non sarei qui a parlarvi o un anno fa
due non mi ricordo fatto un video messo
su youtube è diventato virale interviste
tv ho fatto un libro è diventato molto
virale ho fatto interviste tv e ora mi
recassi scrivere il film
tutto questo in un anno tutto questo
perché io ho messo un video su youtube
e allora io mi chiedo sempre no me lo
merito
cos'ha di diverso dagli altri nulla non
ho nulla di diverso da un altro ragazzo
l'unica differenza che io l'ho fatto mi
sono mosso
e mi sono adattato alla dinamicità di
questo momento e allora ho capito che in
questo periodo l'unico limite a noi
stessi siamo noi stessi e dobbiamo
sbrigarci a trovare quello che ci piace
lo dico ai ragazzi devono sbrigarsi
perché poi ci si diverte poi ci si
diverte ma bisogna farlo ora
ora seneca diceva che la fortuna è
l'incontro tra la preparazione e
l'occasione
ma si sa nega fosse vissuto e sono
sicuro
nell'epoca di angry birds non l'avrebbe
detta questa frase non l'avrebbe nemmeno
pensato perché non solo noi possiamo
prepararci e attendere ora possiamo
crearci le occasioni da soli da soli
viviamo in un momento pazzesco ma non se
ne siamo ancora accorti
non abbiamo ancora capito le
potenzialità che questa connessione
globale ci può dare
non abbiamo ancora capito dove volerci
bene di più come comunicare di più come
connetterci di più tra le persone
io vedo politici che potrebbero fare
delle scelte coraggiose dei cambi di
rotta incredibili sarebbe questo il
momento e non lo fanno
vedo dei genitori che potrebbero educare
i loro figli in un modo nuovo più
divertente più dinamico e rimangono i
genitori di sempre
vedo dei professori dei professori che
potrebbero accendere il fuoco negli
studenti e insegnano la tettonica a
placche vedo dei famosi che potrebbero
parlare a milioni di persone dicendo dei
messaggi e dicono solo cazzate
vedo il marketing che si insinua negli
spazi giovanili per definire dei canoni
di perfezione di bellezza che escludono
quasi tutti e vedo dei giovani che
stanno lì fermi a guardare youtubers che
scoraggiano davanti alla gente
aspettando che qualcosa
da per sbaglio
viviamo in un mondo pazzesco ma non
abbiamo ancora trovato il modo di
renderlo tale
grazie
[Applauso]